Film Courage: Does a director
automatically deserve respect?
Jason Satterlund, Filmmaker:
No, I mean I think that the
director automatically wants respect
but they don't necessarily deserve it.
When you see frustration from directors it's
because they don't have any respect and people
are just walking all over him that usually comes
from a director that is not prepared or not
prepared and just not doing the job
that they're supposed to be doing
it. They need respect, they should have
respect because you're in charge of some
usually something larger even if it's a smaller
production, you still got some money on the line
but they you got you're the person in the position
of a pile of money, you have a target that you're
aiming for at the end of it with some sort of
story or something. You have to dictate things
to all these other departments and if they
don't have your respect they are not going to
be delivering their best work more than likely
because if they don't like you, if they don't
respect you or don't want to be there, they're
going to probably just try to they're just trying
to power through the day that's a really bad that
you don't want your team members in that position
and I don't think that that if you find
yourself in that position it's this is not
necessarily because you have experience
or not that's not usually doesn't have
anything to do with it it's usually has to
do with your preparation directors who are
not prepared really lose the respect of their
crew very quickly because the worst possible
thing you can do on set as a director is not know
what you want to sit there the clock is ticking
and you're going should we put the we should put
the camera so if we put the camera here and then
ah it makes everyone crazy and they're going to
start rolling their eyes and being very frustrated
with you and they're going to start a second
guessing your decisions and things like that
coming into your location beforehand and knowing
they're going to enter through this door and
they're going to go out to that door and I want
to just move the camera this way you don't have
to know every little detail but having an idea
of what you want it's super important and you
could do that without experience and if you don't
know how to to even shoot a scene you can get your
DP to help you with that as long as what you want
that becomes from preparation even having like an
idea of say for example a wardrobe you want I want
it to look like this guy has been up all night
that can be enough of a description for your
wardrobe person at least now they know what
you want okay so he's he slept in his clothes okay
good and so a little bit of wrinkles in yeah yeah
that kind of thing if you came in and you're like
I don't know he's just wearing like clothes like
normal that's maddening to work for you're going
to lose the respect of everybody really quickly
so it's absolutely vital to have respect but it's
not something that you will get just automatically
but you can get it by making sure you're doing
the work so shot listing and storyboarding yep
shot listing storyboarding is very helpful you
don't have to storyboard necessarily there's a
lot of schools of thought on that it depends
on the style that you're going for sometimes
you don't have time so like there's a show
I've been working on where we're running so
fast there's not time for storyboards there's not
even time for a shot list but at least knowing
the basics even like I'm prepared as much as I can
be in the moment I know that these two characters
are coming in and this is their objective and we
have to get them back out and we have to do it in
five minutes or less so at least having some goal
posts to hit at a minimum is helpful the more the
better it is and the easier it is for your team to
work with you what's your image of a bad director
badger I've seen a lot of bad directors I can
picture them in my mind that the first believe it
or not the first sign I see of a Bad director is
someone who doesn't know how to talk to an actor
I think think about what it takes to be a
director you can do it the best place for a
director to be is like television you can go into
a television and the DP already is set to look
the this the writers wrote everything for you
the actors know their characters and you don't
really have to do anything but the the the DP
is probably going to be able to set it up and
while we normally shoot it when the guy goes
over here and he cooks dinner there this is
normally how we shoot the scene okay great the
actors are still going to know what you want
so if you don't know how to talk to them and
they're and they're feeling alone and vulnerable
that that's that's a problem and that is the
one job that no one can really help you with
someone else can light it someone else can get
all the costumes ready in the stunts and stuff but
someone's got to talk to the actors someone's
going to give them emotions and help pull moments
out of them especially if they've shut down who
else is going to do that for you you it's up to
you so there's no more important job than that
I think how do you gut check yourself to know
hey am I moving into bad director mode yeah if I
feel like I'm in danger of being a bad director
I'm waiting for all the commas to appear below the
video like you are a bad director if I feel like
I'm edging into that territory it always comes
down to my prep if I find myself department heads
are asking me so what do you want for the color
of the walls and I haven't thought about that yet
I know that especially if we're approaching
the shoot I know that there's a problem and
especially if there are gaps like what I've
noticed is is what I was called bad directing
it's really easy to focus just
on one aspect of the shoot like
oh it's going to be in this place all lit with
Christmas lights and and it's going to be shot
on a Steadicam and we're going to spin in a
circle cool so what are the actors doing oh we'll
figure that out when we get there you haven't
really thought about that department too much
that's that's that's usually my gut going alarm
bells you you need to take a minute and sit and
think about that this comes back to a big thing
I think we all struggle with which is resistance
your gut you inside know what you need
to do to be successful but sometimes for
whatever reason boop it comes up
where you you just don't want to
you'll resist sitting down and writing out
your shot list because it feels a lot like work
so I know that if I if there are there's usually
that thing and sometimes it's shotless and I like
doing shot lists that's what's so crazy but
if I feel like I haven't done it or see that
I haven't done it and my alarm bells are going off
inside I'm definitely leaning into bad territory
and I feel it on set because there's always this
little sense of inner panic that comes up where
I don't know what I'm what I'm doing here
it's it is a really uncomfortable bad spot
to be in when it happens because it's
already hard enough on set it's already
and where else it comes up is where I
think that I don't need to think about it
whenever I approach a situation where it's just
another breakup scene we shot a bunch of these
it's just gonna be in the ice cream shop the two
thing they're going to leave and I don't put the
work in because I don't feel like I really need
to that's usually when things really go south too
oh the ice cream shop is closed and they and the
actor is allergic to dairy oh well I don't know
what to do that because that kind of thing
will happen it just happens all the time so
which is why you prepare which is why you
do the work ahead of time you're preparing
for Murphy because Murphy will show up he
will make no mistake about it that's why
you prepare because everything's going to go
sideways on you at some point it just will so
you've brought up resistance a lot
are you a fan of The War of Art
yes The War of Art, yes because that's how it
starts right he talks about resistance that that
really rung my bell when he talked about that like
because you the thing about resistance that's so
sinister is that no one else can tell you we can
we're really good at making ourselves look busy
even to our partners or on social media
but we know if we're resisting we're the only ones
who know generally if you're supposed if that you
have that screenplay that you're supposed to
be writing and you just aren't no one's your
partner may be looking you'd be oh he works
on it every day but is he though am I though
we only we know it and so it's yeah it and it can
look like all sorts of things it can look like
it can look like exercise
every time I sit down and write that oh I just
need to go for a walk oh guess what you're not
doing while you're walking you're not riding
it could look like I think he even says in the
book it could be sex could be a resistance
thing you just suddenly I'm really horny
yeah for every person is different social media is
probably the biggest resistance blocker which is
and social media is a killer for art it's
killer it doesn't favors whatsoever it's
there really isn't any purpose to it
especially for artists like what are
you doing if like what do we really need it
for how is it actually helping your career
we like to we like to kid ourselves and tell us
that oh well people need to know that I'm busy
do they though like how many jobs have
we legitimately gotten from Facebook
I mean unless you're in part of a Facebook
group that you post a job and you happen
to be one of the first five that do it and
they're looking for an art department person
I can't think of it I people will message me
and say it looks like you're busy but I've
never landed a job from one of those social media
platforms it's all about the grand advertisement
to show people that you're more important than you
are that's usually the point of social media is
yeah it's not the point of everything to
advertise to the world that you're more
successful more good looking more that your
life is so great and perfect probably isn't
that what we do as humans yeah we just want to
fool everyone into thinking that we're something.